you're thrown into a series of six
mystery games with 400 other players a
pot of 44 million dollars is online but
more importantly if you lose you die
other channels have covered the tactics
to winning the specific games and
honestly the show itself does a pretty
darn good job of showing you creative
solutions to its various puzzles but
today we're gonna help you survive when
you're going in blind just like the
contestants this is how to survive the
squid game
mild spoiler warning for some of the
games and strategies hello internet
welcome to film theory the show that's
brought to you by our totally not made
up sponsor for today's episode usb power
banks are you an off-duty police officer
who went out of your way to infiltrate a
secret society running a brutal death
game in the hopes of discovering a
long-lost family member if so a usb
power bank is the product for you this
device fits into your pocket is smaller
than a cell phone and can keep your
camera powered for days on end so that
when you do finally perform a miraculous
escape from death game island you have
more than a few minutes of video and a
50 word notepad file to show for your
efforts usb power banks seriously what
were you thinking anyway i finally got
around to watching squid game along with
most of the rest of the us at this point
and i loved the series it was tense it
was clever it was also completely
misunderstood by everyone watching it
you see the thing is being called the
next hunger games the new battle royale
the cinematic version of fall guys the
thing is these comparisons really miss
the mark because fundamentally this
isn't how the games in the show work and
if you're one of the people making that
comparison it's likely going to get you
killed don't worry most of the
characters in the series fell to the
same trap and uh let's just say it
didn't end well for him but have no fear
matpat is here by the time you're done
with this video you'll understand the
real way to survive the six rounds of
playground games regardless of what
individual challenges you're faced with
so the next time some random guy in the
subway offers the a hundred thousand won
to flip his paper square or when season
two finally launches because let's face
it this smash hit is absolutely getting
itself a sequel you'll be prepared to
survive the squid so pay attention the
information today might just save your
life and make you rich in the process
for the 10 of you out there who still
haven't watched squid game here's the
briefest of summaries just so you get
through today's theory gion is a down on
his luck gambler who's in dire need of
some cash he's got loan sharks after him
his mother can't afford her surgery and
on top of that he's going to lose
custody of his daughter because he can't
afford to pay a lawyer desperate he
agrees to play the highest stakes game
imaginable he's whisked away to a remote
island with over 400 other competitors
where in order to win they have to
survive six different children's games
some of them are pass fail challenges
like red light green light where failure
results in execution others are player
versus player games like tug of war
where the losing team falls to their
death as for why you'd possibly want to
risk your life in a game like this well
each death adds a hundred million won to
the prize pool 100 million won can you
believe that now all of you are
scrambling to google for that conversion
rate don't worry i did it too when i was
watching the show and so did everyone
else based on the google trends search
results for juan to us dollar conversion
it actually amounts to about 84 000 per
death considering that there are 456
contestants you're talking about a
potential prize pool of 38 million
dollars but be warned once you start
playing you're not allowed to stop
playing and those who do refuse to play
have to worry about clause number two
consent form clause 2 a player who
refuses to play will be eliminated when
they say elimination they mean a bullet
and your head intersecting in an
unpleasant way the only way out once the
games have started is consent form
clause 3. if all of the players agree to
stop playing the games are allowed to
end that's actually a mistranslation by
the way it's if the majority of players
vote end the game that's why subs are
always better than dubs so anyway with
the rules laid out let's get to the
strategy like i mentioned before the
players don't know what games they're
going to be playing until they get to
the death island if they're observant
they can piece together clues based on
the wall decorations around him but
still it's not gonna give him much time
to prepare or practice and so that's
what we're gonna assume today that we've
just signed up and have no idea what's
in store for us in this massive game of
death what should our general strategies
be first we shouldn't assume that just
because people are dying that this is a
death game because it's not the rule
states everyone here will participate in
six different games those who win all
six games will receive a handsome cash
prize if you survive you win and sure
while each death boosts the pot it's not
like a battle royale or hunger game
scenario where there can only be one
left standing here there can be more
than one winner and that's important it
means that the survival of one person or
even a group of people is not directly
negative to your personal survival which
then opens up the question should you be
sabotaging your fellow players in order
to boost the prize pot and advance
yourself this is a dilemma that actually
pops up repeatedly throughout the series
in the second game song woo figures out
the game before anyone else does
punching a shape out of a fragile
honeycomb candy knowing this he
immediately chooses the easiest shape
and then encourages the other players on
his team to split up getting them to
take shapes that are much more difficult
and much more likely to lead to their
elimination obviously there's all kinds
of moral and ethical reasons why you
shouldn't intentionally try to kill
other people but what songwoo does here
in game 2 is one of the stupidest moves
that we see anyone make across the
entire series the people he chooses to
sabotage are people that have agreed to
team up with him the players who in the
event of a fight are more likely to have
his back as opposed to say planting a
knife between his shoulder blades oh
wait that's exactly what we see happen
they come to his rescue the following
night when everyone tries killing each
other but teaming up isn't just about
keeping people and your personal
alliance safe keeping more players in
the game for longer means more chances
for other people to help you survive
again take that honeycomb game as the
example in it players are given a needle
to punch out their shape which is fine
for easy shapes like a triangle but not
very effective for the more fragile
shapes like the umbrella or star however
one person in the group our hero gion
out of desperation comes up with a
completely out of the box strategy
ignoring the needle entirely and licking
the candy so the shape can pop out this
in turn saves multiple other contestants
who copy the strategy people who
otherwise would have been eliminated
just like the rest that's why it's
stupid when the players try to kill each
other between games two and three
because these are men whose lives were
saved by the person that they're now
attempting to eliminate you know what
they say two heads are better than one
so 50 heads should be even better and
400 heads is even better than that it's
why the internet hive mind is so good at
solving puzzles everyone brings their
own experiences and expertise to the
table so let's just say that you were
i don't know faced with a challenge that
involves jumping across panels of glass
with 50 of those panels being tempered
and safe to stand on well it would be
really helpful if the group had someone
who is a glass expert that could tell
the difference between tempered and
untempered glass oh wait that's exactly
what happens except instead of sharing
his knowledge the glass expert hides
this fact until the end after
practically all the other players have
died this is stupid not just from a
statistical angle but also from a
strategic one considering that most of
the games are timed everyone else
realizing that they're just blindly
guessing on a coin flip that could cost
him their life wastes time every second
that you're hiding your knowledge is the
second that the group isn't making
progress as a result our glass maker
despite having the knowledge that should
have kept him alive through this
challenge ultimately dies because he
runs out of time had he shared it from
the get-go mostly everyone could have
survived what was one of the most
disastrous and difficult challenges of
the batch also can i just digress here
for a minute this one bothered me i just
didn't really like this challenge i get
that it was a cool visual and
interesting concept but the challenge
just didn't work for me it didn't seem
to be based on a playground game like
all the others the game makers cheat by
turning off the lights midway through
which directly counteracts their whole
everyone has a fair chance motto the
whole putting people into a specific
order felt unfair and then the way they
conclude it with a giant explosive
finale puts everyone's lives at risk it
was just good spectacle but also
something that felt kind of cheap
alright rant over of course there is the
elephant in the room every player who
dies adds more money to the prize pot
but that's the wrong way to think about
it let's assume that like we see in the
show there are six rounds and that there
will be at least three games that
require 50 of the players to be
eliminated this would be games like
tug-of-war and marbles where some amount
of death is guaranteed that means that
your portion of the prize pot is already
going to be sitting at a hefty 800
million won 668 000 us dollars even
before any additional deaths from the
other games if you're someone like gion
who has loan sharks to pay off a family
member surgery to pay for and an
ex-spouse to fight in court that amount
should cover everything while still
leaving you with enough to make a down
payment on a new house there's also an
economic principle called the law of
diminishing utility which states that if
someone is down on their luck having an
extra eighty thousand dollars is a huge
huge massive deal if you're guillan that
money has a lot of use but if you're
already standing to win over six hundred
thousand dollars another 80k on top is
certainly nice but no longer is the
life-changing sum of money that it once
was once your basic needs are met as
income increases you gain a
correspondingly smaller and smaller
increase in your life satisfaction yet a
slightly nicer car a slightly nicer
house therefore it's not something
that's worth risking your life over this
is surprisingly a topic that the last
episode focuses on though for spoiler
reasons i'm not gonna play the clip no
don't get me wrong i'm not saying that
any winner of the squid games shouldn't
have that money but what i am saying is
that there's a tipping point where each
additional dollar earned is less and
less worth risking your own life to
achieve and by just playing the game
with survival as your first priority you
wind up with plenty of money to change
your situation while also minimizing
your risk of losing that life so you
know you can go on and spend it
obviously there's gonna be rounds where
you're forced to fight for your life and
eliminate other players but if you don't
have to kill people then don't never
thought that's a sentence i'd have to
say but here we are but there is one big
concern that you have to be aware of
clause number three at any point the
players can vote on whether or not to
end the game if the majority of players
want out that causes the game to end not
just for them but for everyone in order
for you to walk home with your money you
have to complete six games but people
will probably vote to escape the games
if they're put into a position where
they're almost certainly gonna die so
with that in mind let's go back to the
glass bridge unless you have outside
knowledge of what tempered and
untempered glass looks like the game is
generally decided by random coin flips
and by coin flips i mean the first few
people in line coming down with a mild
case of death for the good of the group
in the challenge there are 18 sets of
panels worst case scenario you have 18
deaths the best case scenario is zero
deaths with the person in front
correctly guessing every time but fat
chance there as player number three
correctly estimates when he's three
panels in probability then i'll get
everything
this one in 32 768. overall if you're
first in line you have a one in
144 chance of survival the average here
is nine deaths with the probability
distribution curve basically looking
like a bell curve which you can see
using any binomial visualization tool
yep have one of those handy right using
that probability chart we can see that
the first six people in line are
basically screwed having less than a
five percent chance to survive while the
people going 13th and later have a 95 or
better chance to survive but even if
you're trapped in the game with no
calculator it doesn't take a whole lot
of brain power to determine that you do
not want to be one of the first nine
people to play so you as a smart player
hopefully chose not to be one of the
first few people in line but even if
you're feeling good about your odds of
survival remember that for you to
actually make it across the bridge you
need the game to happen let's say that
the game has been reduced to 13 players
and you're lucky enough to be 13th in
line that's good news for you you have
95 odds to survive however you probably
won't make it across the bridge for the
simple reason that there are good odds
that the first seven people in line are
gonna nope the heck out of there go in
with a majority vote to end the game
meaning that even though you had the
ideal position and would have won you
get nothing good day sir and you see
this is exactly what could have happened
in the show 16 players remaining knowing
that the first nine were likely to die
they could have voted to end the game
right then and there and because they
were in the majority clause number three
would have been enacted game over now
let's take the alternate scenario let's
assume knowledge was shared and
everyone's cooperating at this point
there would have been two 50 elimination
games tug of war and marbles in the best
case scenario 456 players would have
been reduced to 114
by the time you get to the bridge even
if every single one of those first 18
people in line got cold feet they
wouldn't have enough votes to end the
game and instead of most of them being
wiped out we'd expect an average of nine
of those players or eight percent of the
114 player group to get eliminated 92
percent of players surviving to get past
this game pretty darn good odds in short
your chances of survival increase the
more people are around you to take the
blows so now that we've spent a lot of
time talking about what not to do what
can you do to increase your odds of
surviving in squid game apart of course
from playing nice with your fellow
competitors well the first one is
obvious don't panic red light green
light is an easy game and the timer was
very generous as long as you stay calm
and you use your time wisely also just
like with the three clauses make sure
that you're paying attention to the
game's rules for instance we see songwoo
cheat at marbles by misdirecting his
partner but his method for collecting 20
marbles doesn't actually involve
breaking any of the rules that are
established by the game master a player
who manages to take all ten marbles from
their partner repeatedly throughout the
series we see players presented with an
obvious solution like the needle in the
honeycomb game and they just assume that
because this is the default or
recommended way to play the game it must
therefore be the only way to play the
game but rarely is that the case you can
lie to your partner and take his marbles
you can lick your candy until the sugar
melts the problem everyone falls into is
that they assume certain rules are there
when in fact they're not in the glass
bridge episode we see that guillain was
able to take a single marble as a
keepsake with him which ended up being
relevant in that very game a second
third or 20 more marvels could have come
in real handy with that one also with
that glass bridge the rules just state
that you have to jump from panel to
panel for this game you will guess which
one of the next two tiles is the tile
made of the stronger tempered glass and
only step on those across the 18 pairs
of tiles but nothing said that you had
to land on the middle of each panel
landing with your feet on the supporting
bars holding up the glass is gonna
reduce the weight on that glass
ultimately helping resist the breakage
is it breaking the rules i don't know
honestly i don't think so but here's the
thing you know that you're gonna die if
you choose wrong so why not try pushing
the edges of the rules just a little bit
when there's nothing else to lose by
taking a moment to think about the
actual hard rules of the game and not
automatically dismissing unconventional
solutions by assuming that anything else
isn't allowed you might actually be able
to find the loophole that allows you to
survive lastly use your surroundings not
only are the walls giving you clues but
your clothes the bed the springs and the
mattresses all of it could potentially
prove useful were you given a glass
bottle yesterday as a part of your meal
instead of breaking it to try and shank
your opponents why not bring it with you
to your next game tug of war throw it
onto your opponent's platform to throw
them off balance or put glass under
their feet maybe cut the rope so neither
side loses another thing that i want to
get off my chest this is just a terrible
idea i think that doll senses when you
move around that person in front of you
is gonna stop at times that you don't
expect or anticipate if they get shot
that bullet might go through them and
pierce you or their dead body might
knock into you and instead of focusing
on the game itself you're gonna be
focused on another person as you run
down that field which is not where your
attention needs to be in short your
number one strategy to surviving the
squid game should be to ignore song woo
i think he would put us at a
disadvantage if we just choose one you
think for being the smartest person in
the room all of his ideas are dumb i
guess except for the tug of war game
anyway if you happen to meet a
well-dressed man in a train station who
invites you to throw squares of paper at
each other now you know what to do and
that's to say no because unless your
desire to win more than half a million
dollars is greater than your desire to
have more than a 12 chance of surviving
the next week of your life it's not
going to be worth it but hey that's just
a theory a film theory and here's a game
for you press that subscribe button as
fast as you can see how many times you
can press it before this video ends
maybe you'll end up subscribed to this
channel maybe you won't we'll find out
together it'll give me the weirdest data
for unsub to resub to a video of all
time youtube analytics is gonna be so
mad at me for this one